[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here so if you
remember that services apple event back
in march that weird one the one actual
piece of hardware technically that was
announced at that event was this shiny
new titanium apple credit card called
apple card well now it's august
and
actually have one now here so we have to
answer the question what would it be
like
if apple
made
a credit card
[Music]
so this is the card itself like i
mentioned it's made of literally
titanium uh all matte white on the front
and the back super clean as you'd expect
from apple hardware and it's got this
precise laser cut out with your name on
the front and the apple logo and the
chip of course and then on the back is
the magnetic stripe and a goldman sachs
and mastercard logos so the issuing bank
and the card provider for this guy and
right off the bat i know there are other
metal credit cards but i don't have any
so this is very different from the rest
of what i normally carry it's the same
thickness as a normal card but quite a
bit heavier being metal and also way
less flexible feels more durable i'm not
going to try to actually break this
thing but it flexes way less it's more
solid and then there's this sort of
chamfer that goes all the way around and
gleams and catches in the light as you'd
expect from a solid block of metal this
uh this is the wallet i carry right now
it's made by trove i'll link it below
since people always ask about it but i
don't carry cash i just have a couple
cards with me and the card key actually
to get into the studio literally wrapped
in a dbrand skin so i don't have to look
at the brown color that it actually is
but uh the apple card would fit right
into a normal wallet it's the same size
as every other card not too much thicker
the only thing that actually concerns me
here is the white finish
like how does it wear does it start to
chip off or does it start to discolor
over time
not exactly sure but it does look super
clean right out the box so to activate
it it comes in this colorful packaging
with instructions wake iphone and hold
here so i just touched the top of my
iphone right to the bottom of the card
right around here and it comes up in ios
just like any other pair of airpods or
something to pair
you activate the card here and it adds
it to your wallet app and you're
officially good to go this is
essentially a credit card
for iphone users
like that's just that's what it is
meaning it's basically an extension of
the apple pay that you could already use
but now in a physical credit card form
so all those places that don't accept
apple pay but you still want to use
apple pay so it shows up in the wallet
app you have a physical card to do it
and then on top of that there are a lot
of legitimately nice features in the
wallet app that you may already know
since it's a credit card this time there
is a slider to show how much interest
you'd be paying versus different payment
schedules
with this really clean intuitive ui the
red color like actively discourages you
from making the minimum payment and
racking up more interest so that's
pretty cool and then fun fact so neil at
the verge actually tweeted that he
noticed in the app the color gradient of
the card
actually means something so it starts
off completely white like mine before
you spend any money on anything with the
card and then anytime you spend money at
a different merchant or category it adds
colors to the gradient so i wanted to
test that out for myself so i went to b
h and literally i pre-ordered my galaxy
note 10 with the apple card and sure
enough instantly like literally a half a
second after i pressed the buy button on
b h's site my app populated with that
purchase and added the color to my card
so i'm starting my gradient of colors
now
so yeah i can confirm that's what's
happening here it was really
impressively fast and then it gives you
a purchase history where you can dig
into each purchase every transaction and
see it on a map so if you don't
recognize it you can look up exactly
where it came from honestly a lot of
stuff that i wish my current banking app
also did and then i guess one of the
most underrated pieces of it is it's all
secured with face id so even if someone
finds your card or someone steals your
card they can't use it because they
don't have your iphone or even if they
do have your iphone they don't have your
face you can also remotely deactivate
the card from the wallet app which is
also where you can grab the card number
if you want to pay for things online
using a form like i just did with b h
and then of course it's just also very
clean there's no card number on the card
that's a little more secure i guess and
there's no signature since that's not
required anymore it's in the app so you
just get this
nice
super clean look it's pretty nice
actually now to be honest as a credit
card it's actually not that amazing of a
credit card interest rates are okay you
know 12 and up depending on your credit
score if you get approved but like you
know you won't see this on any best
value cards lists anytime soon the one
cool thing is instead of giving you
points that build up over time it just
gives you straight apple cash the next
day so you can spend it 24 hours after
you've earned it you get one percent
cash back on everything so like that
note 10 i just bought on b h with the
card i got one percent cash back i get
two percent cash back on everything that
i use apple pay for
and you get three percent cash back on
everything you buy from the apple store
from apple i don't know who's spending
that much money in apple that that would
be a thing you'd care about but hey
that's what you get i don't know i kind
of just see this thing as a status
symbol slash
flex of the decade honestly this is uh
very
gratuitous that that's just what it is
one thing i do have to say though just
because the features are so good and so
intertwined with the wallet app on the
iphone
beware
of the ecosystem if you thought the
walls of the the garden weren't high
enough already just because people don't
want to leave the iphone because of
imessage and the green and blue bubbles
people don't want to leave the iphone
because they have all the storage and
icloud already imagine trying to switch
to an android phone but you don't want
to now because you also have to give up
your credit card
like that's nuts so beware this is
obviously another tool that can be used
to sort of trap you in the apple
ecosystem but you already knew that
right anyway thanks for watching this
quick one just figured i'd give a quick
update since there is technically
actually new hardware around but uh
that's just about all there is to it
also shout out to the waveform podcast
is now officially
launched i'll have a link right below
that like button if you want to check it
out episode one is up
and uh we'll have more info on that
coming soon either way thanks for
watching catch you guys later
peace
you